ahora vamos a explorar cómo factorizar
una expresión llamada diferencia de
cuadrados y la razón por la que se llama
diferencia de cuadrados es porque es
algo como x cuadrada menos 9 esta es una
diferencia o una resta entre dos
cantidades las cuales son cuadrados esta
es literalmente x elevada al cuadrado
menos 3 elevado al cuadrado es la
diferencia entre dos cantidades que han
sido elevadas al cuadrado y esto resulta
muy sencillo de factorizar y para ver
cómo podemos factorizar esto déjenme
pausar esta parte por un momento y
revisar un poco la multiplicación de
binomios
así que dejemos esto de lado por un
momento antes de que les dé la respuesta
de cómo factorizar esto hagamos un
pequeño ejercicio vamos a multiplicar x
+ a por x menos a donde a es algún
número y para resolverlo vamos a usar la
propiedad distributiva dos veces podemos
tomar x +
y distribuirla en la equis y en la a así
cuando multiplicamos por x obtenemos x x
x x cuadrada a por x esa x y luego
cuando multiplicamos por la negativa
bueno eso es igual a menos a x menos a
cuadrada entonces estos dos términos de
enmedio se cancelan y nos quedamos con x
cuadrada menos a cuadrada nos quedamos
con una diferencia de cuadrados x
cuadrada menos a cuadrada aquí tenemos
un resultado interesante que x cuadrada
menos al cuadrado es igual a x más a por
x menos
y podemos hacer esto para cualquier
valor de a ahora podemos usar este
patrón para factorizar esto aquí cuál es
nuestra muestra de estrés
esto es x cuadrada menos 3 al cuadrado o
podemos decir menos nuestra a cuadrada y
si tenemos que 3 es nuestra
para factorizar esto vamos a decir que
esto es igual a x más nuestra a que es
igual a 3 por x menos nuestra a que es 3
tenemos x 3 x x 3 ahora hagamos algunos
ejercicios para reforzar esta idea de
factorizar diferencia de cuadrados
digamos que queremos factorizar que
cuadrada menos 25 tiene que ser una
diferencia de cuadrados no funciona con
una suma de cuadrados bueno en este caso
tenemos ya que está elevada al cuadrado
y tenemos que confirmar
si 25 y 5 al cuadrado así que esto va a
ser igual a ye más algo por qué menos
algo y que es ese algo bueno esto que
tenemos aquí el 5 elevado al cuadrado
así que es igual al 5% menos 5 y la
variable no necesariamente tiene que
estar primero podríamos tener 121 menos
voy a escribir una nueva variable menos
be cuadrada esto es una diferencia de
cuadrados porque 121 es 11 elevado al
cuadrado así que esto va a ser igual a
11 más algo por 11 menos algo y en este
caso ese algo va a ser esta variable que
está elevada al cuadrado esto es 11 + b
por 11 menos b
así que si ves una diferencia de
cuadrados es decir un cuadrado que se
resta de otro cuadrado y hay un número
que es un cuadrado perfecto y una
variable a la que le puedes sacar la
raíz cuadrada
entonces puedes decir ok esto es igual a
la primera cosa que está elevado al
cuadrado más la segunda cosa que está
elevada al cuadrado por la primera cosa
que está elevada al cuadrado menos la
segunda cosa que está elevada al
cuadrado ahora algunos errores comunes
que he visto en las personas es que
dicen o que ya es fácil reconocer una
diferencia de cuadrados entonces esto es
igual a ye cuadrada más 25 por ye
cuadrada menos 25 y eso no está bien lo
importante es darse cuenta de lo que
está elevado al cuadrado y de este lado
la aie es la que está elevada al
cuadrado y aquí es el 5 el que está
elevado al cuadrado esto es igual a
gemma 5 porque menos cinco los animo a
que practiquen esto tenemos toda una
sección de práctica en khan academy
donde pueden hacer muchos ejercicios